people in the comments of this video
wanted to see a Time slice style
rotating camera shot so I put the
Phantom on the bolt motion control rig
and programmed a two-point orbital move
that lasts one second keeping the magnet
the same distance from the lens three
two one go
I think that was pretty good
look at that there was like a Fab bit
that got sucked into the middle and went
thinner did you see that yeah it's like
flat planes that you can see the sort of
Jank light it really highlights the the
3dness that you can see which ones are
closing because they're in the shade oh
yeah it gives it some depth yeah it
almost looks like the circles that we
were seeing in the bottom last time are
actually there's two of them and they're
coming out almost 45 degrees from each
corner like almost if you put like a
donut on each corner of the magnet yeah
like a crooked donut yeah that's insane
that's wicked isn't it maybe one day I
should try and program a move that's
slightly faster we can try this again
but that is a lot more information I'm
surprised